twelve boys in their soccer coach
trapped in a cave in Thailand for more
than two weeks are finally home this
morning
most of the players visited a Buddhist
temple near the cave today they honored
the former Thai Navy SEAL who died
during their rescue mission mission we
talked with two of the boys on their
first full days with their families Anna
Warner is in mae sai thailand near where
the boys live and a good morning to you
good morning and you know people say
they have trouble understanding how the
boys were trapped in the cave so quickly
by rising floodwaters well this is the
reason we are in the middle of a monsoon
rain right now look at how much water is
coming down and how quickly luckily
those boys escaped and we spoke with two
of them a smile lit up the face of
eleven-year-old tightened finally back
at home after more than two weeks in a
cave now surrounded by family what did
dad say to you he said you are safe and
home now titin told us we are so happy
what was it like in the cave for you
it was dark and quite scary tight and
said scary for his father Tana woot - we
first spoke with him three weeks ago
when Titan was still trapped in the cave
earlier this week he told us now he just
wants a normal life for his son I want
to support him he told us and I want him
to remember whatever happens he still
has family what helped tighten in the
cave he told us I had coach eight by my
side he said he encouraged me at a news
conference Wednesday the boys 25 year
old soccer coach nicknamed ache
described keeping the group calm in the
cave I said to them don't be scared
and there will be people looking for us
it would be another nine days before the
boys would be found by British divers
while huddled on a Ledge above flood
waters
[Music]
we're fourteen-year-old to do and help
the group communicate with their
english-speaking rescuers thank you
everybody
pray we visited with a Doon Wednesday at
the church in Thailand where he has
lived for almost 10 years he growing up
in here gooshie Mau is the pastor of the
church he helped teacher do in English
he is the future leaders of the church
in here for the next generation one of
the first things that Doon did when back
at the church eat his favorite food
Kentucky Fried Chicken a dooms life has
been difficult even before the cave he
is stateless not a citizen of Thailand
or any other country
his parents slipped him out of Myanmar
and into Thailand nearly a decade ago to
escape ethnic conflicts they are still
in Myanmar but at the church a dune is
surrounded by people who love Him and
he's grateful
and this is why they tell people to
watch out for caves in a monsoon because
those caves basically become underground
rivers we've watched thousands of
gallons of water come down in the last
hour with no sign of stopping John it's
been raining continually for about three
hours today and a Werner and Thailand
thanks Anna it's amazing to see you know
that that rushing water really tells a
story Anna for sure but that adoun don't
you love the woman saying here have some
chickens good though a for life from
there ask for better promotion yes I
suspect somebody in the PR department is
working on that press release right